lleva el nombre del compositor favorito
de Hitler fundado y dirigido por Jeff
Jenni rigoyin el grupo paramilitar ruso
Wagner juega hoy un papel importante en
la Guerra de Ucrania lejos de su Coto de
caza favorito África Sudán Libia Chad
Guinea y Madagascar según el centro de
estudios estratégicos internacionales
sus mercenarios están ahora presentes en
unos 15 países de todo el continente el
modelo africano de Wagner es ahora bien
conocido la depredación de los recursos
locales a cambio de sus servicios el
resultado es una enorme ganancia
financiera incalculable pero esencial
para financiar sus operaciones en
Ucrania y para pagar bien a sus hombres
también presentes en Siria y Venezuela
Los mercenarios de wagnes son acusados
en varios países africanos de violación
y tortura desde hace varios meses el
grupo gana fuerza en Ucrania
está perdiendo muchos hombres cada día
especialmente en bakmut donde los
combates con el ejército ucraniano han
durado meses es imposible saber cuántos
hombres tiene Wagner porque decenas de
miles de prisioneros han sido reclutados
en la cárcel y otros tantos según su
líder murieron en el campo de batalla
Vladimir Putin ha negado durante mucho
tiempo la existencia del grupo y aún
niega a cualquier vínculo con él en
noviembre pasado los paramilitares
finalmente salieron de las Sombras e
inauguraron este imponente edificio en
el corazón de San Petersburgo la ciudad
donde prigollín y Putin se conocieron y
que alberga otro de las actividades de
Wagner su propaganda para el kremlin una
fábrica de trolls que emplea a miles de
soldados digitales el segundo ejército
de Jeff Jenny prigollín